we appear to be approaching potentially
two more arrests of failed former
president Donald Trump first and
foremost is that Fanny Willis in Georgia
is stepping up security and precautions
for this next uh season so to speak of
announcing indictments that will start
in July and run through September there
is the belief that Trump is getting
indicted there but separately there is a
rolling stone article Trump's lawyers
warn him get ready to be indicted by the
feds the former president has angrily
complained in response to predictions
that if the justice department is going
to charge him then what about Joe Biden
what about Joe Biden and the article
says some of Trump's lawyers and
advisors have given the former president
an unwelcome if not unexpected message
in recent weeks you should expect to get
indicted this year now we've talked
before 4 about the seemingly
underailable train that is Trump
speeding towards the Republican
nomination and in those hypotheticals
the question about what could derail it
has mostly gone to if Trump gets
arrested and is so bogged down by
criminal cases that he quite literally
can't get out on the campaign Trail in
any substantive way it starts to affect
the Republican electorate and people who
currently say they would be voting for
Trump in the primary were today move on
to someone else maybe DeSantis or maybe
someone else uh but short of that Trump
seems to have an unobstructed path to
the nomination
and yet we now seem to be potentially
within months of trump getting arrested
two more times the article also says
several legal and political counselors
to Trump have bluntly informed him they
expect the justice department to charge
him in the criminal investigation into
his hoarding of Highly classified
documents following the end of his
presidency two sources familiar with the
matter tell Rolling Stone
this of course comes on the heels of
Trump's indictment by local prosecutors
in Manhattan in April for falsifying
business records later this summer
officials in Fulton County Georgia are
expected to make a decision about
whether or not to indict Trump
Trump's attorneys and confidants told
Trump that though they view the federal
investigation as BS they would be
surprised at this point if he wasn't
charged particularly for alleged
obstruction of justice and have urged
Trump to prepare for yet another
historic fight looks like they're going
for it one of the sources says people
close to the former president have
discussed with him what we think is
going to happen soon and how he and
everyone else needs to be ready for it
it would be crazy not too so there's two
things going on here one there are very
real political implications we are
quickly getting into the heat of a very
hotly contested Republican primary it
will be an unprecedented situation where
uh the current president will be running
for re-election that's Joe Biden against
a former president
who was already defeated by Biden and
then will be running again against him
unprecedented and you throw into the
middle of that already won maybe two
maybe a third arrest and it is going to
be complete in total chaos if we go
beyond the political implications
progress is slow but we are seeing some
progress now I still don't believe that
we are going to see Trump do a day of
prison or jail I don't think we're going
to see it in any of these cases however
if you look at the degree to which this
has gone from this stuff should be
investigated to there are investigations
to we're talking to a grand jury to it's
looking like the grand jury wants to
convict you Trump has been arrested once
and maybe and may end up arrested three
times that is Major progress in seeking
to find uh justice for the alleged
wrongs of the Trump presidency so we
will be following the forthcoming
possibility of more arrests very closely
it is important to also understand that
while Trump seems to have an
unobstructed path to the nomination
unless multiple arrests take them off
the campaign Trail the so-called
anti-trump Republican movement seems to
be imploding let's talk about that next
one of the best ways to support this
show is by supporting our sponsors today
one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear it is spring temperatures are
rising many of us know all too well
about the sweating and the sticking and
the chafing but that's only when you use
traditional underwear when you use
sheath underwear it's no longer a
problem sheath underwear is
ergonomically designed with separate
compartments in the front to keep
everything dry cool and separate and to
keep you comfortable they come in a
zillion different designs something for
everybody the quality is amazing super
long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for
yourself and my audience gets 20 off
with Pacman go to
sheathunderwear.com slash Pacman the
link is down below